is especially dangerous with the white
Pieces Just great opening preparation
for someone so young it's rare to
achieve such a kind of dynamic kind of
bulletproof opening repertoire but he
has that and Magnus starting in
provocative fashion he's gone for the
modern defense and uh we've seen him
employ this before yesterday with
success Magnus Carlson Prague has
clearly come prepared why it's h-born
marching forward to Simon you must be
loving this right now it's a very
interesting idea in a chessboard course
that I did along with Richard Palace so
that here you go G4
um okay wow he's actually given up the
exchange what an absolute Maniac so
that's all I'm going to say prag prag
wants to kill me he's your hero actually
the evaluation bar loves White's
position yeah and that's rare the
computer normally is very skeptical
unless there's a forcing variation but
uh Magnus caught by a surprise just
pushing a pawn forward one square maybe
he wants to use his Queen just to defend
the pawn next to it you know get
allowing a knight to come into that
Square stopping a queen coming over the
defender he's actually gone for this one
straight away and I can just see him
getting crushed here I mean uh okay he's
trying to keep the position closed and
take away a square for the White Knight
that makes a lot of sense but it's now
White's move can why increase the
pressure here why he just castles he
doesn't care about being exchanged out
to play maybe the worst move on the
board whoops yes you just get your queen
trapped so oh dear yeah so there's a
little bit of danger here well Magnus
has played you say when you're getting
attacked don't open up your king so
what's he done he's open up his King so
very risky move that as well but he's
got it I guess he's got to take risks
okay forget that one that's just too
dangerous but yeah Prague has said yeah
I will welcome that opening and now the
bishop has developed that that's a much
better move don't take the pull with the
Rook Simon just calm down and okay he's
played a more positional approach right
I mean it blocked in the bishop he's
blocked in the bishop but he's keeping
his strong pawn and Center on could
backfire here maybe this Pawn will drop
I'm not sure yeah he chooses I like this
one as well Simon in a Blitz game you
play this and you just Checkmate and you
win this is much more sensible get the
Firepower in first right there's a
Target you always look for a square that
you can attack in your opponent's camp
and there's a way here that white can
easily bring a bishop in threatening
Checkmate in one move there because
black doesn't have a pawn in front of
the king so that's why going the other
way it's a bit more blocked over there
and you want to put your King on the
side where your opponent can't get
through to it with his pieces beautiful
piece you are
but then when they get captured they'll
feel so sad it's true you could say good
job good job and then and they're
talking about a piece that could get
captured wow there's a Pawn on F7 that
is up for grabs Craig having a big
attack a winning attack okay he does
play the best move I was about to say
stockfish does say on our screens in
front of us uh that one move is
significantly better than the others
every other move would have given black
an advantage but Prague finds it we've
called that Prague style before he's uh
he's very good at finding uh those moves
when they're far better than the others
and he does take this Pawn with the
queen if white takes this Pawn okay he
does find the best move of course then
Knight takes Pawn would have been very
complicated but uh Magnus okay he does
decide it's time to counter-attack you
know more passive play this one right
yeah yeah and we saw this position
earlier we might be headed in that
direction potentially
um so the skewer are now Rook takes
Bishop yeah giving up the White Queen
but after a capture on this Square I
guess the Knight takes and plants itself
yeah three pieces for a queen or Rook
takes F7 immediately was also and the
other option I guess so okay this hasn't
happened but yeah okay this is I mean
crazy we can forgive that uh Prague for
not going for this queen against three
minor pieces
um yeah who knows who's better here he's
gone for this queen takes Bishop but we
didn't think
that uh Magnus was in serious trouble
now did we um he's getting some
coordination uh with his pieces and he
seems to be over the worst uh I would
have fought here at least this Queen's
struggling for squares as well she's
only got two safe squares okay she
chooses this one there were two options
yeah suddenly it feels like Black's
coordinating Black's Knight is nicely
placed Black's Rook at some point will
come into the action uh black can take
this Pawn at will whenever he wants
yeah it's in the balance yeah Magnus has
uh survived and it was all about
survival that's I think the key interest
when you're defending just focus on one
thing you can counter-attack later
and okay he hits the White Queen
where will she go exact same reasons
yeah and uh
uh I like white spawn structure and is a
win the most likely result in this game
if it is Prague or if it is Magnus
uh yeah I mean even if the computer says
zero point something I just don't see
how this position is going to be a draw
it's just so wild so imbalanced uh not
just in terms of material but also Pawn
structure King safety it's wild so a
draw gotta move it awesome is that a
crazy one okay there is a crazy one and
practice played it that's when that's
when cheating would help right yeah
because if you're new in that situation
the bars change you'd look for something
a bit outrageous so you your eyes would
be drawn to this kind of move I don't
know why it works it's just you know
okay wow two exchanges down yeah what is
the count here black has two Rooks in
return white has a knight a bishop and
coupons I mean someone did some nuts for
me please it's been too long a day but
it's a crazy material imbalance and
kings are Under Fire just incredible
stuff I would just move the Rook of Iowa
Magnus and you know black also has some
tricks up their sleeve like the move
that I would be planning and plotting
would be to actually move the Knight and
put it on the D1 Square how does the
computer think it's just like such a
small Advantage for either side it looks
like someone should be winning
okay the bishop does move
and uh very sensible yeah I mean White's
pieces are looking good and now Magnus
is trying to swap off right yeah similar
ideas to what Ivanka has in mind
potentially
um the White Knight capturing the Black
Knight it wouldn't end a Checkmate
because this check can be blocked by the
White Queen I just saw that someone was
worried about my computer after the
coffee spilled on it I'd just like to
clarify it's not my computer it's oh yes
if steam starts coming up
I apologize you know and right now again
material count black has two Rooks with
ten white has a knight a bishop and
except four points it is four points so
night Bishop of four that's also worth
ten wow okay yeah this so it's equal
that's enough counting for me today we
need that guy back again to the laughs
on this game I think but uh this
position is just crazy because you have
to let go of some pawns and okay he's
decided to let go of the G2 Pawn but the
white king is now going to get mobilized
some Brooks I would be terrified I mean
maybe yeah I mean I mean is Prague
winning this a computer seems to think
so evaluation bars are really woken up
and uh I love this last idea just giving
away one Pawn just not even caring that
black syrup came and took upon but the
white king is going to join as an attack
if it as an attacking piece in this end
game it's uh similar to what Magna
showed against Iranian active Kings
they're just an extra piece and okay the
BlackRock moves
wow is this Rook getting trapped maybe
wow I've got to be really careful where
you go with this oh that Rook does have
two safe squares I was gonna say either
you come across on a dark square or you
go back up the board uh sit on a dark
Square you don't want to get hit by
White's Bishop I mean so hard I mean
it's kind of game where it's probably
easier if you turn off the compute
evaluation because it changes so much
because it's so Dynamic and either side
could win this even though it says
Prague is well in charge I mean I guess
his pawns are just very scarier simply
those pawns Are Gonna Roll and the
Knight and Bishop work very well
together the Rooks are disconnected at
the same time
um also just mentioning Venture it
doesn't seem to be having a great day
today I hope he hope he comes back into
the mix Jackie I want to I want to see
him qualify him still we're Chucky fans
here so yeah we'll see you tomorrow
about that yeah
uh maybe we can jump in to explain why
white probably has the advantage here
um just dropping back with a knight
check okay wow I was I was thinking yeah
black would love to just eliminate one
of these pieces but uh yeah now suddenly
the white porn structure is broken up
the black king is going to take this guy
in Simon you made a sound there no I I
think this is now you know if anyone's
gonna win this it'll be blackmail again
it's changed again probably a draw but
yeah you've lost all your advantage by
allowing that countersack white needed
to keep the Knight intact maybe just
Retreat it to this Square keep these two
Pawns in your pocket for later it's
Black's dream to get rid of his Rook for
your knight and two pawns and this
barrier is no longer existent and uh
yeah oh sorry me and my Iris the king is
coming in WoW Magnus has played a really
weird move this last one dropping The
Rook back the whole idea I guess is that
if the king marches forward the black
king will also step out the way and the
king is cut off on this line
Anish Gary hey congratulations with the
win in your final game
thank you thank you what has today been
like Anish
you want my hot take on the hot matter
what is it are you gonna pretend you
know we're gonna ignore the elephant in
the room there
I mean it's like when you play Pokemon
I saw you play spooker so you you pull
up on the first then then you know
another card you keep laughing and then
another card and you keep laughing but
um yeah I mean it looks like uh you know
it's clearly insinating something but uh
you know until you catch someone you
cannot um
you cannot do anything so
wrap it from the head with Magnus but he
just doesn't want to play hands it seems
and it's quite quite interesting that
the game after that he played so well I
was thinking you know like you might be
disturbed but he was just undeserved
really a special human being for sure
are you like the rest of the the Chess
World basically calling for Magnus to
explain this and maybe come with some
evidence against Hans
but I think it's pretty clear that um
that he doesn't have um he doesn't have
it
um
because if he had there would be no need
to do that it's pretty clear to me
um that he is convinced or near
convinced that uh that is the case these
things they stick and then afterwards
the big boys they they don't trust you
anymore you know and that's just that's
uh that's not good so yeah I mean
definitely you know with this drama like
every time you need some new information
to keep the drama going but today you
know with this thing will definitely
keep perspiring for a while just yeah
crazy great stuff going on and it's not
clear how it will end because as we see
like there is no I don't think Magnus
has any anything more than what's there
I mean there is the repeated cheating
online there is the
the I mean slightly uh weird
character that Hans is portraying but
you know I mean yeah just the fact that
all that that doesn't mean that he
cheats all the time or doesn't mean that
he cheats over the board or well and you
play Hans name on tomorrow in round 10
Anish are you uncomfortable playing him
let me be very Frank
um because I
um I knew about all this everybody knew
about all the stuff about online
shooting and we know about online
cheating by multiple other players well
okay it would be uh because these things
they just uh leaked and I mean these are
not the top players but the young
players who have been banned on various
websites
um I so I always thought there is
possibility that house is cheating but
looking at my own games
um I had a conviction that he never did
that against me because he usually plays
very badly but so either way um yeah
there are swing levels um level swings
in his play and uh that might very well
do with the fact that he's very young
there are also many uh level swings uh
with everyone but in particular with
young players because they know some
positions better they know some position
less they looked at some lines they
didn't look at some others they studied
some Catalan lines you know uh didn't
look some I don't know antibi lens so um
yeah I'm eager to play Hans I've done
very well against him before
he plays very forward against me so I'm
not concerned but of course he he seems
to be improving his rating is rising
whatever the reason is whether he's uh
just legit very strong or um what uh
Mario is trying to intimate but either
way uh it is a of course an exciting
game that can be dangerous as well so
I'm looking forward I mean whenever I
play I always push these thoughts away
and I heard that Magnus said the same in
some interview but I don't know what
happened to him like whenever
you have to just assume that the
opponents don't cheat it's like one of
these
it's one of the psychological issues
that players
struggle to play a struggle and normally
you don't withdraw you just I mean if
you can't deal with them you'd go to
therapist we wish you best of luck
tomorrow as well in your fight to
qualify for the Knockouts thanks for
joining us thank you maybe that is
what's going on with Magnus resigning
against Hans Neiman this one is it now
going to be a draw
yes I'm slightly surprised Magnus went
for this last move uh giving up his Rook
for whites bishop and pawn white is a
pawn up but some calculation is needed
if the white king can make its way and
win Black's Pawn
sir came over but Magnus knows his
endgames and there's not going to be a
way for white to win this one black
keeps the opposition like he does here
blocks off the advance of the white king
and uh we're just gonna see a Shuffle by
both Kings here no way no way through
this is End Game 101. King opponent game
is so tricky but if you know your stuff
you can save a lot of points yeah this
one uh it's so unfair chess you see the
most exciting game roller coaster game
they always seem to end in drawers
however and uh King versus King did you
see that Magnus just clapped applauded
Prague and we have a draw wow that is uh
so interesting Magnus calls and I'm
pregnant on that they keep having the
best fights in the mouthwater Champions
chess tour and this one went all the way
down to King versus King a draw between
the 17 year old and the world number one
Magnus Carlsen now we are oh look at
that